HEARING OF THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WHEN WELCOME EVERYONE
THE HEARING WE HAVE -- SEVEN
ITEMS -- TODAY FOUR OF THEM.
ARE ON CONSENT OF WHO WAS ON THE
RIVER [inaudible] ONE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY OF MY APOLOGIES.
THIS IS NOT A ELEVATED AGENDA
THREE ARE ON CONSENSUS FOR ARE
NOT -- WE DO NOT HAVE IT -- BERG
A. R. QUORUM YET SO WE WILL
BEGIN AND WILL -- ESTABLISH A
QUORUM ONE MORE MEMBERS ARRIVED --
THE FIRST ITEM WHICH I'LL BE CO
PRESENTING WITH -- CENTER ALLEN
IS A CA ONE SALAS CENTER MORE
LOCK TO TAKE THE GAVEL
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THE CENTER WIENER DATA.
IF YOU WISH TO PRESENT THE BILL
OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO DEFER TO
CENTER ALLEN.
I JUST WANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO
ENSURE THAT YOUR THE COMMITTEE.
I APPRECIATE THAT SUMMER OKAY
CENTER ALLEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS
IF WE COULD HAVE FOR YOUR GOOD
ATTENTION.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A ONE THANK
YOU VERY TO MISS REST CHAIR --
AND MEMBERS I'M I'M VERY PLEAED
TO BE HERE ALONGSIDE MY MY JOINT
AUTHORED A FORMIDABLE ARRAY OF
CO SPONSORS THE PRESENT SENATE
CONSTITUTION MOMENT.
ONE I WHICH WOULD PLACE A
MEASURE ON A FUTURE STATEWIDE
BALLOT ASKING VOTERS TO REPEAL
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
THIS PROVISION WAS PASSED BY
VOTERS IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY AND IT REQUIRES
MAJORITY APPROVAL.
BY THE VOTERS OF A CITY OR
COUNTY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION -- ACQUISITION OF A
PUBLICLY FUNDED LOW RENT HOUSING
PROJECT THAT MEASURE WAS A
DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE FEDERAL.
HOUSING ACT OF NINETEEN FORTY
NINE WHICH WAS PART OF PRESIDENT
TRUMAN'S FAIR DEAL TO HELP LOWER
INCOME.
POST WAR FAMILIES MOVE OUT OF
THE SLUMS AND INTO BETTER LIVING
SITUATIONS.
NOW I DON'T NEED TO EXPLAIN
ANYONE HERE ABOUT HOW MUCH THE
GOLDEN STATE HAS CHANGED SINCE.
NINETEEN FIFTY OUR SOCIETY AND
HAD VERY DIFFERENT ATTITUDES
ABOUT RACE AND ETHNICITY CLASS
AND POVERTY AT THE TIME THEY
WERE ALSO FAR LESS TOOLS
PROVIDING RESIDENTS WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ALTER A BLOCK
PLANS FOR YOU HOUSING THERE WAS
NO.
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT THE
WHAT NO BROWN ACT NO COASTAL ACT
FAR FEWER LAWSUITS IN GENERAL.
I TODAY ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
STANDS AS ANACHRONISTIC AN
EXPENSIVE CONSTITUTIONAL BARRIER
THAT SUBJECTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO A WEB REGULATIONS A COSTLY
ELECTIONS.
THAT END UP DRIVING UP THE PRICE
OF BUILDING PUBLICLY FINANCED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
HOUSING THAT IS APPROVED BY THE
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE LOCAL
ELECTRIC.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONLY TWENTY TWO
AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE AROUND
HOMES FOR EVERYONE HUNDRED
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS --
I DON'T NEED TO EXPLAIN THIS
ISSUE TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
HOUSING COMMITTEE BUT A MEMBER
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S RENTERS
SPENT MORE THAN A THIRD.
SORRY MEANT SPEND MORE THAN 30%
OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF OUR
POPULATION SPENDS MORE THAN HALF
OF THEIR INCOME JUST. FOR A
PLACE TO LIVE 40% OF
CALIFORNIANS ALSO CHOOSE ALSO
LIVE CLOSE TO OUR BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE.
SO THESE HIGH HOUSING COSTS OF
OF YOU KNOW WITH THESE HIGH
HOUSING COSTS OF OF ONE SIMPLE
AND SMALL FINANCIAL SETBACK
COULD SPELL CATASTROPHE. TOO
MANY OF OUR NEIGHBORS ARE ONE
MISTAKE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
HOMELESSNESS AND IT'S PART OF
WHY WE'RE SEEING AN UPTICK IN
HOMELESSNESS SO NO ONE PERSON OR
POLICIES TO BLAME FOR THE
SITUATION IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORNIA VOTERS HAVE SPENT
TIME AND HAD HAVE SAID TIME AND
TIME AGAIN THAT.
THEY WANT -- TO THEY WANT US AS
THEIR LEADERS TO DO BETTER BY
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS OR
STRUGGLING TO FIND.
IN A FOR HOUSING.
SUPPORTING STATE LOCAL BALLOT
MEASURES THE DEDICATE HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAXPAYER MONEY TO ADD TACKLE OUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
FOUND IN THE STUDY I'VE GOT
SEVERAL A LOS ANGELES TIMES
ARTICLES I'M HAPPY TO SHARE WITH.
THE MEMBERS -- THERE IS A
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
THAT ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR HAS
PROVEN TO BE A AS AS INCREASE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION VERTICALLY.
FOR LOW INCOME FOLKS IN THE END
OF THE DAY ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR
IS TO ALLOW THE LOCAL ACTED
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE WHERE
ACCOUNTABLE LOCALLY TO THE
VOTERS LOCALLY. TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE SAY AS TO WHETHER THEY
WANTED TO BUILD THIS KIND OF
HOUSING -- WE NEED TO TAKE THIS
MEASURE OUT OF THE THE
CONSTITUTION I'M PROUD OF THE
FACT THAT SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE INVOLVED IN PUTTING IN THE
CLUSTERS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
HAVE NOW NOT ONLY COME AROUND TO
A NEUTRAL POSITION BUT ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT -- FOLKS AS
DIVERSE AS OUR CITIES -- THE
WESTERN CENTER ON POVERTY BUT
ALSO OF THE REALTORS AND FOLKS
WHO ARE ON THE BUSINESS AND SO.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TO THINK
AND AND AND Q. MY MY GOOD FRIEND
IN OUR JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
IS WORKING REALLY HARD ON THIS
AS WELL.
I THANK YOU CENTER ON FOR YOUR
COLLEAGUES ON SO ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR IS A SCAR ON THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND NEEDS TO BE
REMOVED -- AS SHOULD NEVER BEEN
IN THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE BUT
IT'S NEVER TOO LATE -- TO
CORRECT A VERY TERRIBLE MISTAKE
THAT THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA
MADE IN ADOPTING OTHERS
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISIONS -- WE
AS WE ALL KNOW HAVE A TERRIBLE
HOUSING CRISIS AND A SHORTAGE OF
HOUSING OF ALL TYPES -- INSTEAD
OF CALIFORNIA I AS WE MOVE
TOWARDS TRYING TO CLOSE A THREE
AND A HALF MILLION HOME SHORTAGE.
ON A GOOD CHUNK OF THAT SHORTAGE
IS A HOUSING THAT'S AFFORDABLE
TO LOW INCOME -- VERY LOW INCOME
AN EXTREMELY LOW INCOME.
RESIDENTS -- AN ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR MAKES IT XCEPTIONALLY HARD --
TO GET THIS TYPE OF HOUSING
APPROVED HOUSING WITH THE PUBLIC
SUBSIDY AND THAT KIND OF HOUSING --
USUALLY REQUIRES A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY -- SO WE SHOULD BE
MAKING IT EASIER TO PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS -- INSTEAD OF
PUTTING UP NOT AS BARRIERS BUT
HUGE BARRIERS ALL RIGHT NOW THIS
KIND OF HOUSING PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED -- LOW INCOME HOUSING
IS SINGLED OUT FOR UNIQUE
TREATMENT NO OTHER TYPE OF
HOUSING IS REQUIRED. TO GO TO
THE VOTERS TO BE APPROVED ONLY
HOUSING WITH PUBLIC SUBSIDY
OFFER OUR LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
AND THAT SENDS A VERY.
POWERFUL NEGATIVE MESSAGE ABOUT
WHAT WERE PRIORITIZING IS A
STATE -- SO LET'S MAKE IT EASIER
TO BUILD ALL FORMS OF HOUSING TO
SOLVE THIS CRISIS -- AND
REPEALING ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
YOU SENATORS SINCE YOU'RE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I DID YOU WANT TO GIVE YOUR
OTHER WITNESSES AT LEAST THIRTY
MINUTES EACH -- ARAB WELL
WITNESSES -- WITH US TODAY ARE
OF SYLVIA SO LEASE REPRESENTING
CITY OF LOS ANGELES ON YOUR
LAWLER FROM THE WESTERN CENTER
OF LAW AND POVERTY.
AND JENNIFER STRUCK FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
MR TURN MEMBERS SYLVIA'S ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ON BEHALF OF CITY OF
LA MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A CA ONE AM PROUD TO
BE A CO SPONSOR.
AS SENATOR ALLEN MENTIONED THERE
ARE ONLY TWENTY TWO AFFORDABLE
AND AVAILABLE HOMES FOR EVERYONE
HUNDRED EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS AND IN LA
COUNTY ALONE WE WOULD NEED TO
ADD MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
MEET EXISTING DEMAND -- AT THE
TIME WHEN THE STATE CALIPHATE IN
THE CITY ARE FACING HISTORIC
PORTABLE PRIZING IT CRACKED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR JUST ADDS
ONE ADDITIONAL BARRIER TO THE
CREATION OF THIS MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING.
IN LOS ANGELES RESIDENTS HAVE
APPROVED SIX SUCCESSIVE
PROPOSITIONS FROM 1-993-220-0082
ADDRESS ARTICLE THIRTY FOURS
REQUIREMENTS AND GAVE THE US
CITY AUTHORITY TO FINANCE UP.
TO FIFTY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS
HOWEVER AS NEW FUNDING SOURCES
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING COME
ONLINE PARTICULARLY STATE
SOURCES LIKE PROPS WANTED.
TO AND SB TO REVENUES THE CITY
WILL BEGIN TO EXHAUST THIS.
EXHAUST THIS AUTHORITY IN
CERTAIN NEIGHBORHOODS.
UNLESS ARTICLE THIRTY FOURS
REPEAL THE CITY WILL LIKELY HAVE
TO GO BACK TO THE VOTERS TO
APPROVE ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THE VOTERS WILL
INCREASE THAT AUTHORITY HOWEVER
WE FEEL THAT IT IS NEED IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSE OF THIS ISSUE IN REPEAL
THIS LANGUAGE FROM UR
CONSTITUTION FOR THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT AND ARE PROUD TO
SPONSOR SCA.
ONE THANK YOU YOU MISTER THESE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS RETURN
COMMITTEE ON YOU ALL ARE WE HAVE
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY -- AS BOTH AUTHORS HAVE
ALREADY MENTIONED CALIFORNIA HAS
A TREMENDOUS SHORTAGE OF HOUSING
AFFORDABLE TO EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS -- I THINK
PEOPLE REACTED WITH SHOCK TODAY
WHEN THE LOS ANGELES HOMELESS
COUNT NUMBERS WERE RELEASED BUT
IT WASN'T A SHOCK IT WAS
PREDICTABLE BECAUSE WE AREN'T
PRODUCING ENOUGH EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSING UNITS. TO HOUSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DANGER OF
FALLING AND HOMELESSNESS AND WE
CANNOT DO THAT WITHOUT A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PUBLIC
SUBSIDY AND UNFORTUNATELY
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR STANDS IN
THE WAY OF BUILDING THOSE UNITS --
IN A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA THAT
PURPORTS TO VALUE DIVERSITY
INCLUSION HAVING AN ARTICLE IN
THE CONSTITUTION THAT OPENLY
ALLOWS VOTERS TO CHOOSE TO
DISCRIMINATE IS UNACCEPTABLE AND
IT'S TIME FOR IT TO GO
[inaudible]
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
SPECTRUM HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
CESSATION OF REALTORS WE ARE
ALSO A CODE C<c.cyan> A PROUD CO</c>
SPONSOR OF A CA.
ONE I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST POINT
OUT THE ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
REQUIRES A DEVELOPMENT
CONTAINING LOW RENT WILLING
FINANCED IN WHOLE.
OR IN PART BY FEDERAL STATE OR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BE APPROVED BY
THE LOCAL VOTERS.
THE LAST SEVENTY YEARS ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR HAS PROVEN TO BE A
MAJOR HURDLE TO THE CONSTRUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
A SENATOR WINNER POINTED OUT THE
ARTICLE SINGLES OUT ONE TYPE OF
HOUSING FOR VOTER APPROVAL AND
DOES NOT JUST APPLY TO PUBLIC
HOUSING BUT CAN ALSO AFFECT
FIXED INCOME DEVELOPMENTS.
WHICH OFTEN CONTAIN UNITS
PARTIALLY SUBSIDIZED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
WEARING A LOCAL POPULAR VOTE TO
APPROVE ANY INSTANCE OF GENUINE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WORKS TO
WIDEN ECONOMIC INEQUALITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
BALLOT BOX PLANNING GENERALLY AN
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR SPECIFICALLY
IS USED AS A POWERFUL NO GROWTH
WEAPON FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T WANT DEVELOPMENT.
ON AVERAGE COMPLIANCE WITH
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR ADS ANYWHERE
FROM TEN TO EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER UNIT TO PEOPLE WITH
PRE CONSTRUCTION COSTS.
IN AN EFFORT TO AVOID THESE
COSTS COSTS THE PUBLIC SECTOR
PROVIDES LOW INCOME HOUSING
THROUGH A CONVOLUTED SPREAD A
FUNDING SOURCES AND MARKET
INCENTIVES.
CREATIVE AVOIDANCE OF ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR SHOULDN'T BE
NECESSARY AND ITS ARCHAIC
REQUIREMENTS NEED TO BE REPEALED.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PLAYED A
LEADING ROLE IN DETERMINING THE
LOCATION AND AMOUNT OF HOUSING
IN THEIR JURISDICTIONS. FOR
DECADES DEVELOPERS HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED FROM CONSTRUCTING UP
ENOUGH UNITS TO KEEP PACE WITH
JOB AND POPULATION GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE RESULT RENTS AND HOME PRICES
CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET.
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY THE
SENATORS AND ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
SCA ONE SIMPLY SEEKS TO REPEAL
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
LIFTING A MAJOR ROADBLOCK TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
ALL OVER THE STATE.
WITH THAT SAID WE RESPECT THE
REQUESTER AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU MISS
BACK ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
JULIE SNYDER REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
BRING A WHITE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
A LUIS BRONTE WITH CALVET
CALIFORNIAN BE AM PROUD SUPPORT
PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR -- COOKS
BECAUSE MONSTER ON THIS
INITIATIVE AS WELL.
JANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO INTO A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES IN VERY STRONG
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE DUGGAR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR SECOND A HOUSING
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN SUPPORT.
A SEVENTY I WAS WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VICTORIA FEARS OF EAST BAY FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT.
I'VE BEEN WILL BE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA RENTERS LEGAL
ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION FUND IN
SUPPORT.
LESLIE CHRIS CELIA WITH SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
COME ON SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SENATOR ALLEN WOULD
YOU -- WHO WOULD YOU ALLOW US TO
ASK A FEW QUESTIONS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVING QUESTIONS
WHETHER?
I HAVE -- ONE WE HAVE SOME
HISTORIAN OF PUTTING THIS ON THE
BALLOT -- OVER THE YEARS
INCLUDING LAST IN -- NINETY
THREE THEY WERE ALL UNSUCCESSFUL
WHAT WHAT WILL BE DIFFERENT THIS
TIME.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
PREVIOUS ELECTIONS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED MORE RECENTLY THAT
THERE I THINK THERE'S MUCH MORE
OPENNESS FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS
THE ELECTORATE IS CHANGED --
SOME OF THE CONDITIONS HAVE
CHANGED -- YOU KNOW.
WE THINK THAT THE ELECTORATE IS
CHANGING THE WAY THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL THIS TIME.
AND I THINK THAT'S REFLECTED IN
THE NUMBER OF ALSO TO SURPRISING
RESULTS THAT HAPPENED RECENTLY --
ON ON SAY WHITE BALLOTS THAT
HAVE BROKEN.
NORMS IN MALLS FROM THE PAST.
AT ALL I I I THINK THAT THE
PUBLIC CONSCIOUSNESS AROUND THE
HOUSING -- DISASTER THAT WE'RE
IN RIGHT NOW MAYBE IT WASN'T A
DISASTER IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE IT IS NOW -- AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PUBLIC TO THE
POLLING STATEWIDE -- A FIVE OR
TEN YEARS AGO HOUSING WAS NOT
THE TOP OR EVEN ONE OF THE TOP
ISSUE STATEWIDE WAS IN SOME
CITIES.
BUT NOT STATEWIDE IT IS NOW
CONSISTENTLY HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS -- SO I IN THE
ELECTORATE IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE NOW THAN IT WAS IN.
NINETY THREE SO WE WE HAVE SEEN
CHANGES -- OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
THE SPEAKERS WAS FROM CALIFORNIA
EMB.
SO WE HAVE PUSH BACK THE OTHER
SIDE BUT I'VE BEEN GETTING
EMAILS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR WONDERING WHAT I'M
DOING.
TOUCHING ARTICLE THIRTY FOR THE
CONSTITUTION I WAS CONFUSED AT
FIRST WHEN I STARTED GETTING THE
THE EMAILS BUT THERE ARE STILL A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT FEEL LET.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO SELECT
THEIR NEIGHBORS AND SO THAT'S AN
INCREDIBLE PSYCHE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DEAL WITH -- AT GOING
FORWARD SO VOTING FOR THIS --
BILL IS IS JUST ALARM THE VOTERS --
TO WAY IN.
THAT'S ABSOLUTE RIGHT IT'LL JUST
ALLOWS THE VERGE NGUYEN IN THE
OTHER THING I'LL MENTION IS.
THIS DOESN'T IMPACT THE RIGHT OF
ANY CITY GOVERNMENT.
DO YOU STILL MAINTAIN THEIR OWN
ZONING LAND USE PLANNING RULES.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE SEEING YOU
KNOW SUPPORT OF CITIES IN THIS
IN THIS CONVERSATION -- SO THE
THE CITY GOVERNMENT THAT IS
ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE OF THE
CITY WHO ARE POLITICALLY
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE PEOPLE WILL
STILL BE ABLE TO MAKE
DETERMINATIONS -- AND SO IN THAT
SENSE ARE STILL A GREAT DEAL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY LOCALLY.
YES SO I'M JUST SAYING THAT
MAYBE VOTING FOR THIS TODAY
DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN THAT
MAKE YOU MIGHT APPROVE OF THE
OVERALL.
CONCEPT YOU'RE JUST SAYING HEY
WE'RE GIVING YOUR SHOT YOU'RE
GIVING THE VOTERS OPPORTUNE WAY.
RIGHT TO HAVE ANY OTHER FOR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
COMMENT EITHER OF YOU ARE BOTH
OF YOU.
WELL I ON IT YEAH I I JUST
APPRECIATE THIS THIS
CONVERSATION I THINK -- IT'S
LONG OVERDUE -- AYE AYE YEAH
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE AWAY THIS
THIS THIS IS A BARRIER THAT IS
ACTUALLY COSTING TAXPAYERS MONEY --
AS WE ARE TRYING TO WHERE WE'RE
TRYING WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH
WAYS TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
IDEAS AND SOME.
ARE ARE -- GO FURTHER THAN
OTHERS BUT THIS THIS IS A CLEAR
BAY AREA RIGHT NOW -- IT NEEDS
TO BE RECTIFIED I'M SO I'M JUST
PROUD OF THE COALITION WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BUILD A
PARTICULARLY -- THANKFUL.
APPOINTMENTS ARE SOME OF THE I'M
I'M PARTICULAR THANKFUL TO ON
THE REALTORS AFTER COMING ON
BOARD -- AND WORKING WITH OUR
FOLKS IN THE WITH THE ANTI
POVERTY COMMUNITY AT IN A IT'S A
IT'S A GREAT COALITION WE PULL
TOGETHER AND I I REALLY DO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOOK.
GREAT WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
YET SO WE CAN TAKE A VOTE.
BUT AS SOON AS WE DO WE WE WILL
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
I'LL NOW TURN THE GAVEL BACK
OVER TO SENATOR WIENER
[inaudible]
WHAT -- I WOULD JUST VOTER SOON
AS A THIS [inaudible] FIVE YEAH
[inaudible]
ALMOST.
OKAY.
THANK YOU -- SEC OKAY -- OKAY I
NEXT TO OUR CALL -- ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB.
ONE FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND ALSO ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
AS YOU KNOW BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THIS -- TOPIC
EXTENSIVELY -- AND I KNOW YOU
ARE VERY INVESTED IN THIS TOPIC
ON A CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
A HOUSING CRISIS.
AND IN ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA
MEANT MANY OTHER STATES SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS HAS BEEN AN ISSUE.
THAT WE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
BOTTOM LINE THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
MANY TYPES OF PROGRAMS -- THAT
HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED MANY BEST
PRACTICES AND MODELS AND YET IT
CONTINUES TO ELUDE US AS FAR AS
SOLVING THIS.
AB. ONE FORTY THREE WHAT EXPAND
EMERGENCY HOUSING TO INCLUDE
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. EIGHT THIS
WOULD PERTAIN TO ORANGE COUNTY
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE AS WELL AS OTHER
COUNTIES AND CITIES -- INCLUDED
IN CURRENT LAW THAT HAVE
DECLARED A SHELTER CRISIS.
AS WE TALK ABOUT WHAT IS A
SHELTER CRISIS -- BOTTOM LINE I
ORANGE COUNTY.
SADLY HAS A MODEL FOR THAT TEN
THAT MODEL IS SIMPLY NOT HAVING
ENOUGH HOMES TO HELP HELD A
HOUSE ARE HOMELESS.
WE HAVE A THE INFAMOUS JUDGE
JUDGE CARTER WHO IS NOT ONLY
SAID THAT ENOUGH IS ENOUGH BUT
THAT HE WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH CITIES TO MAKE SURE THEY
PROVIDE THIS HOUSING.
AND ONE OF THE MODELS IS TO
CREATE EMERGENCY SHELTERS AS
QUICK AS WE CAN GET THEM UP AND
THEN MOVE TOWARDS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING -- WE HAVE
SEEN AND TALKED ABOUT THE LARGE
INCREASE NOT ONLY IN ORANGE
COUNTY BUT LOS ANGELES JUST AN
INCREASE IN 16%.
SAN FRANCISCO 16%.
AND EVEN WORSE IS WHAT'S THAT.
A DOING NOT ONLY TO OUR
BUSINESSES TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
DO LIVE IN THE HOME BUT TO THE
CONDITIONS ON THE OUTSIDE.
THE DAY IN LOS ANGELES THERE'S
ELECTION AND SOME OF THE
LOBBYING FOR OR AGAINST A
FUNDING SOURCE HAS CHAU NGUYEN.
RATS RUNNING AROUND.
THE LA CITY HALL IN OTHER PARTS
IT BILL BEING -- BLAMED ON
HOMELESSNESS BUT SIMPLY THAT
PEOPLE ARE LIVING OUT -- AND
THERE'S A LOT OF CONDITIONS THAT
ARE ADDING TO ALL TYPES OF
HEALTH ISSUES -- WHETHER IT BE
OUTBREAKS WHETHER IT BE TYPHUS
WHETHER IT BE HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT WE REALLY DID NOT THINK
WE'D HAVE TO BE THINKING ABOUT
IN THIS DAY AND TIME.
SO WE NEED MANY MANY STRATEGIES
ARE BOTH SHORT AND LONG TERM AB
FORTY ONE FORTY THREE WHAT IT A
CREATE FLEXIBILITY TO EXPEDITE
THE CREATION OF SHELTERS.
AND AGAIN PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING -- IT AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE MUST DO IS GET
THE SHELTERS UP THE JUDGE NOW
HAS MET WITH.
EACH CITY ARE IN ORANGE COUNTY
TO ASK THEM TO WORK TOWARDS A
PLAN -- IF THEY ARE NOT WORKING
TOWARDS THE PLAN HE WILL NOT BE --
WORKING -- TO HE WILL ACTUALLY
ALLOW PEOPLE TO CAMP AND PARKS
AND OTHER AREAS AND LIST THE
CITIES ARE MOVING TOWARDS A
HOMELESS PLAN.
A AND HE'S MADE MANY --
CONDITIONS IN SETTLEMENTS WITH
CITIES -- AND I DO THINK THE
ENTIRE STATE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT TOUGH WHAT OUR JUDGES DO IT
NOW I KNOW I HAVE MY FRIEND HERE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY I DON'T KNOW
IF HE AGREES WITH THAT.
BUT YOU GOT TO MAKE PEOPLE DO
WHAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS WANT TO
DO -- SO WITH THAT -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING AND
APPROVING -- THE COUNTIES OR
CITIES ORDINANCES TO ENSURE THE
PRESERVATION AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS ARE NOT ONLY
FOR FIELD BUT THAT THEY ARE
OVERSEEN.
EACH A COMMUNITY OPERATING UNDER
THE BILL MUST REPORT ANNUALLY TO
THE LEGISLATURE -- AND TODAY I
HAVE NICOLE WARD A MAN ON BEHALF
OF ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND REAGAN AND
INJURE.
WHO IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HOUSE SCENE AND SAN JOSE?
NICOLE MORTAL MAN ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE FORTY THREE THIS MEASURE
WOULD EXPEDITE THE PROVISION OF
SHELTER FOR THE COUNTIES AND
SHELTERED HOMELESS POPULATION.
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF THE MOST
URGENT ISSUES FACING THE COUNTY.
IN JANUARY DURING THE COUNTY IS.
HOMELESS POINT IN TIME COUNT IT
SHOWED AN INCREASE OF 43% IN THE
HOMELESS POPULATION TO ALMOST.
700058% OF WHOM ARE AND SHELTER.
THE COUNTY HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF EMERGENCY SHELTERS
WITHIN THE SYSTEM OF CARE.
INCREASING THAT NUMBER BY
110021% BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AB ONE FORTY THREE
WOULD PERMIT THE COUNTY GREATER
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE PROVISION OF
SHELTER WHILE REQUIRING THE
COUNTY TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE STATE OF
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING.
BALANCING BOTH LOCAL AND STATE
GOALS.
THEREFORE THE COUNTY URGES AN
AYE VOTE ON AB.
ONE FORTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON
REAGAN HENNINGER WITH THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE'S HOUSING DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA.
FOR THIS BILL AND TO USE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
THIS AFTERNOON.
SAN JOSE HAS OVER SIX THOUSAND
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN OUR CITY.
WE KNOW THE ANSWER IS HOUSING.
WE HAVE OVER ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AFFORDABLE HOMES
CURRENTLY IN OUR DEVELOPMENT
PIPELINE.
OVER 90% OF THOSE WE HOUSE
REMAIN STABLE THE HOUSE.
BUT THERE'S A CRISIS IN THE
STREETS RIGHT NOW. FOR EVERYONE
PERSON THAT WE STABLE THE HOUSE
IN OUR CONTINUUM OF CARE. THREE
MORE FALL INTO HOMELESSNESS.
SHELTERS AND OTHER INTERIM
HOUSING OPTIONS ALLOW US TO
PROVIDE PEOPLE SAFETY.
RESPITE FROM THE ELEMENTS AND
ACCESS TO SERVICES.
IN SAN JOSE THIS SUMMER WILL
OPEN TO BRIDGE HOUSING
COMMUNITIES OR TINY HOME
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE CURRENTLY CITING OUR FIRST
NAVIGATION CENTER.
OR SHELTER FOR ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE.
AB ONE FORTY THREE WILL HELP US
MOVE QUICKLY.
AND SERVE THOSE WHO ARE LIVING
AN UNIMAGINABLE CONDITIONS
OUTSIDE.
WE THANK YOU COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
TIME AND URGE AND I VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL A SUPPORTIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD STATE YOUR NAME
COLLATION WORK.
OF MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
BOB NAYLOR ON BEHALF OF FEELS
THAT IN COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS -- STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY RESCUE
MISSION IN SUPPORT.
LESLEY GORE CELIA WAS SILICON
VALLEY AT HOME ARE WORKING IN
SAN JOSE AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY
ON ON HOMELESSNESS ISSUES AND
AND HOUSING SUPPORT IN IN
SUPPORT.
CAN BE REDONDO SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND SO
BRIDGE.
FILL THE INSULATION ON BEHALF OF
CITY OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CASING NON WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE CALLERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL THIS.
YES SENATOR DRAW SO.
I VERY MUCH -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
A FEW QUESTIONS -- YOU KNOW WHAT
SOMETIMES THE COMES TO MIND WHEN
IT SAYS WE'RE GONNA SUSPEND
LOCAL HOUSING HEALTH.
AND SAFETY STANDARDS OF WERE
PUBLIC FACILITIES IT WAS A YOU
KNOW KIND OF BRINGS TO MIND.
WHERE THE DANGERS OF THE
POTENTIAL DANGERS AND -- I COULD
SEE.
A BUILDING.
FACILITIES A PLACES THAT.
MIGHT NOT BE OBVIOUSLY IS FANCY --
AS YOU KNOW BIG SINGLE FAMILY
HOME.
ON THE OTHER HAND I'M NOT QUITE
SURE WHERE YOU.
DRAW THE LINE AS FAR AS WITH
MINIMALLY NEEDED TO SHELTER ARE
HOMELESS.
AND THEN WORK WHERE IS IT NOW
UNSAFE SO.
IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION BROADLY SO THAT'S THE
FIRST QUESTION.
AND RELATED TO THAT IS.
WILL THEY BE CONSIDERED
SUBSTANDARD STRUCTURES.
AND IF SO WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
STRUCTURES.
AT A POINT.
WHEN?
WE MAY NOT NEED THE THE SAME
KIND OF FACILITY OF THAT SAME
KIND OF HOUSING SOMETIME IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE QUESTIONS
ANOTHER VERY GOOD QUESTIONS UP
FIRST DOES THIS IS NOT A MANDATE
WHICH MEANS THAT.
THE LOCAL CITIES WITHIN THOSE
COUNTIES CAN STILL MAKE THE
DECISION IF THAT'S THE ROUTE
THEY WANT TO GO IN ORDER.
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN --
QUITE A BIT OF THE FUNDING
COMING DOWN FROM THE STATE.
HE FUNDS AND SO FORTH A CITY
WOULD HAVE TO DECLARE A SHELTER
CRISIS OR EMERGENCY UP TO GET
THOSE CITY SO SOME ARE ALREADY
DOING THAT EVEN WITHOUT THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
BUT AS FAR AS BUILDING THE
HOUSING -- WE WOULD MAKE SURE --
THAT THIS HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS ARE NOT DIMINISHED
IT'S JUST.
THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME TYPES
OF STREAMLINING THAT WOULD ALLOW
IT TO MOVE FASTER AS WE KNOW
EVEN A REGULAR -- TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT CAN SOMETIMES TAKE
TWO TO THREE YEARS FROM GOING
FROM -- NOT ONLY PLANNING
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOPMENT AND
THROUGH ALL THE PROCESSES SO
THIS WOULD HOPEFULLY BE MUCH
QUICKER OTHERWISE WE WOULDN'T
REALLY BE OF OUR OUR GOAL IS TO
GET THESE PROJECTS DONE WITHIN.
TWO TO THREE YEARS WELL THE
FUNDING IS THERE AS FAR AS THE
SHELTERS EMERGENCY SHELTERS --
MANY OF THESE PROPERTIES WOULD
BE BUILT ON CITY PROPERTY AS WE
KNOW THAT SOME OF THE PROPERTY
IS ALREADY OWNED BY THE CITY AND
THEY'RE BUILDING.
WHAT WOULD BE MORE TEMPORARY UP
KIND OF LIKE OF?
THE MODULAR BUILDINGS I'M TRYING
TO THINK OF THE TYPE OF
BUILDINGS THEY BRING ON TO
SCHOOL CAMPUSES WHEN THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL THAT THE PRE FAB TYPE
OF BUILDINGS.
SO THEY ALREADY HAVE SAFETY
CODES AND SO FORTH.
AS FAR AS THE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY GO THROUGH THE CODES
THAT THE CITIES HAVE IN PLACE --
AND THOSE WOULD BE PERMANENT --
SO I THINK THE THE GOING AROUND
SEEK WOODS NOT TO GO AROUND IT
IT'S TO MAKE SURE THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES ARE STILL THERE BUT TO
MOVE IT FORWARD IN A MORE TIMELY
MANNER.
NOT SURE IF THAT ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTIONS.
AND ALSO THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE
OF THE OF MAKING SURE THAT THERE
WAS A REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN OVERSIGHT BY THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT SO THERE
WOULD BE PEOPLE ON WATCH TO MAKE
SURE.
NOT JUST THROWING UP IF YOU WANT
TO SAY SOME TYPE OF UP VERY
MINIMAL HOUSING WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT TENS ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
PLEASE YES SORRY CENTER MORE
LIKE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
FOR PROVISION ANYTHING WRONG.
I THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE THE TIP
HUSTLER -- THIS IS ONLY
APPLICABLE TO TO COUNTY SAN AND
ONE CITY AND ONE COUNTY AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS WHY ISN'T THE BILL --
STATE LEVEL TO IT YEAH.
THAT THAT'S THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION I'M ACTUALLY GONNA LOOK
AT MY NOTES FOR THAT ONE OF
BECAUSE I WAS.
IT'S SO SPECIFIC.
AND I BELIEVE RIGHT NOW WE WERE
JUST GONNA START SMALL AND WE
DID ACTUALLY WHEN THE BILL CAME
OUT WE WERE ASKED BY THE CITIES
MENTIONED IF THEY COULD
PARTICIPATE.
BUT WE JUST PRETTY MUCH STARTED
WITH ORANGE COUNTY AS THAT'S THE
COUNTY I REPRESENT AND THEN --
SAN JOSE AND ALAMEDA ASKED TO
JOIN IN.
AND WE SAID YES.
AND THEN WHEN THE CITY DECLARES
A SHELTER CRISIS IS THAT JUST --
A RESOLUTION OF THE CITY COUNCIL
OR THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
IT'S A VOTE BY THE INDIVIDUAL
CITY.
AND THE COUNTY COULD A DECLARE --
COUNTY CRISIS BUT I BELIEVE IF
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THIS IN BUT
IT IN A PARTICULAR CITY THE CITY
WOULD ALSO HAVE TO DECLARE THE
CRISIS AS WELL.
AND THE CITY YOU MEAN THAT THE
CITY COUNCIL YES.
THANK YOU MISTER JR THANK YOU.
OKAY I SEE NO OTHER COMMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO NOT YET HAVE
A QUORUM.
AND AS SOON AS WE DO WE WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION -- SO WITHOUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO FLOWS.
I WILL I JUST AGAIN SOME OF YOU
HAVE HEARD ME SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS -- IN OTHER
AREAS AS LIFE MOVE FORWARD
SEVERAL BILLS UNDER THIS TOPIC
THIS YEAR BUT UP PERSONALLY.
LIKE MANY FAMILIES I'VE SEEN A
FAMILY MEMBER STRUGGLE WITH THIS
AND IN ORANGE COUNTY JUST IN
THIS LAST YEAR -- WE HAVE LOST
OVER THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DIED ON ORANGE COUNTY SEAT
STREETS JUST THIS LAST YEAR.
AND MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DIED THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED.
NOT ONLY HAVE WE SEEN THAT BUT
WITH THE JUDGE.
CARTER DAVID CARTER SO INVOLVED
HE ACTUALLY.
PULLED THE AUTOPSY.
RECORDS AND IT WAS SO IMPORTANT
TO HIM TO FIND OUT WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON IN ADDITION TO
THEM NOT HAVING SHELTER.
AND MANY OF THEM DIED FROM
PNEUMONIA.
THAT TYPE OF JUST GETTING SICK
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO GET IT
RECOVER AND IF YOU IMAGINE BEING
OUT IN THE STREETS IN YOUR SEC.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GET
SICKER AND THAT ALSO PASS ON
THESE OTHER ISSUES AND MY
BROTHER WAS ONE OF THOSE.
SO THAT'S WHY BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE -- SO
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION AS
SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
NEXT WE WILL GO -- TO WE HAVE --
ONE TWO MORE NON CONSENT ITEMS
ANNEXES SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN --
AND THAT IS AB [inaudible]
SIX SEVENTY WELCOME.
SO -- SENATORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
THIS BILL -- I BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A FAIRLY SIMPLE BILL -- I AM
A BIG SUPPORTER OF EIGHTY USES
ONE OF OUR IMPORTANT SOLUTIONS.
TO HELP WITH THE HOUSING CRISIS
BRINGING PEOPLE IN A SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS -- WORKING
VERY MUCH WITH PARTNERSHIP WITH
OUR LOCAL RESIDENTS AND ALSO OF
COURSE EXPANDING LOCAL --
PROPERTY RIGHTS BY ALLOWING
RESIDENTS TO BUILDING EIGHTY YOU
IF THEY SO CHOOSE --
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA --
H. O. WAYS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS FOR SOME REASON
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO WHAT WE
ARE NOT EVEN ALLOWING CHARTER
CITIES TO DO.
AND THEY'VE THROUGH THE
REGULATIONS COME BLOCK THE
ABILITY OF A HOMEOWNER TO DO AN
EIGHTY YOU IF THEY WANT -- AND I
DON'T THINK THAT WAS EVER
ANTICIPATED WHEN THE LEGISLATION
WAS PASSED WOULD BE IT AS IT MAY --
IT'S REALLY A LOOPHOLE -- SO --
THERE IS OVER FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
IT'S ALWAYS IN THE STATE THAT
MAKE UP.
TO UP TO ABOUT SIX MILLION TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS SO THIS BILL WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THE THE THE M. H.
ALWAYS HAVE TO FOLLOW THE SAME
STATE LAWS CITIES IN CHARTER
CITIES.
AND CAMP PUT ON REASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS ON EIGHTY USE
ALTHOUGH WE DO ALLOW THEM STILL
THE ABILITY TO HAVE AN IMPACT
WITH DESIGN -- SETBACKS THAT
SORT OF THING SO THEY CAN DO IT
IN A WAY THAT CONFORMS TO THEIR
DESIGN STANDARDS AND THAT THEIR
COMMUNITIES BUT WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO BE ABLE TO TRUMP --
INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY OWNERS
ABILITY TO PUT AN EIGHTY YOU IN
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR PARENTS OR
THEIR CHILDREN OR TO RENT OUT IF
THEY WISH.
SO WITH THAT -- I WOULD REQUEST
FULLY QUESTION I VOTED IN WITH
ME HERE TODAY.
IS -- DAVID JONES FROM THIS
TODAY REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
TRUCKEE COUNTY ALL RIGHT WHAT
HAPPENS REPRESENT THE CITY OF
GLENDALE THROUGH VERY GOOD LIKE
I THINK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR A GOOD ANALYSIS -- THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME AS NOTED THIS
IS BEEN DONE BEFORE IT WITH A
TWO WAYS THE LEGISLATION IS
PASSED WISDOM DECIDED THAT SOLAR --
SATELLITE DISHES EVEY CHARGING
STATIONS AND A WATER
CONSERVATION WERE THINGS THAT
WAS WORTHY OFHAVING THE AGE
WHERE RULES PREEMPTED SO WE
THINK THIS FALLS IN THE CATEGORY
WITH.
THE EARLIER TESTIMONY THE CRISIS
OF HOUSING -- AND TYPICALLY FOR
LOW HOUSING KIND OF TRICKY A HAS
HAD.
A DELUGE OF FIGHT OF HOUSING
LEAVE THEIR COMMUNITY THERE I
DON'T KNOW HOW FAMILIAR YOU ARE
WITH IT BUT IT'S FOUR TWENTY
FIVE MILES FROM RENO RENO USED
TO BE THERE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SAFETY NET.
WITH AMAZON AND TEST LOW
BUILDING GIANT PLANTS THERE
THEREFORE DOUBLE HOUSING SAFETY
VALVE HAS HAS ELIMINATED SO
THEIR CRUNCH FOR WORKFORCE
HOUSING IN THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
HAS DISAPPEARED.
WE HAVE ONE OF THE LARGEST H.
AWAYS IN THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
WITHIN OUR TOWN LIMITS.
A SINGLE FAMILY SIX THOUSAND
VACATION HOMES THOSE OWNERS ARE
CLAMORING FOR THE ABILITY TO
HAVE AN H. AWAY MOST OF THEM
LIVE IN THE BAY AREA THEY ARE
NOT RESIDENTS TREKKIE.
BUT THEY WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
SOMEBODY LIVING ON THEIR
PROPERTY THAT CAN WATCH OUT FOR
THE PROPERTY WHEN THEY'RE GONE
FOR THE TWO WEEKS SHOVEL THEIR
DRIVEWAY CAN SNOW SEASON.
AND WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS THING
THAT PEOPLE ACROSS THE STREET
THAT DON'T LIVE IN AN AGE WHERE
ABLE TO BUILD THEIR EIGHT EIGHTY
USE THERE SO.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I THINK IT'S REX THE
PROPER BALANCE OF RESPECTING AS
MUCH AS WE CAN WE DON'T GET
INTRUSIVE INTO THE AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED.
IF IT'S A SENIOR -- H. AWAY
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE AN ABILITY
TO HAVE KIDS IT'S A SPANISH
STYLE H. AWAY.
THE DESIGN HAS TO BE MEET WITH
THE H. WAY REQUIREMENTS SO WE'VE
TRIED TO BE AS RESPECTFUL AS
POSSIBLE TO THE H. AWAY RULES.
AND SO WITH THAT WE ASK FOR
NAVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
FAMOUS CHAIRMAN KEYS DONE HERE
BEHALF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WE LIKE TO THINK THE
OFFERING JUST REITERATE MISTER
JONES I COMMON SO YOU AS WE
FACE THIS HOUSING CRISIS WHEN
HE'D BE LOOKING AT EVERY
OPPORTUNITY. TO VOTE PROVIDER
CITIZENS WITH THE BEST OPTIONS
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE THINK THIS
MEASURE GOES A LONG WAY WE THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR IT INTERACTION WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SECOND HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIANS
PART.
ENDLESS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA
BEEN SUPPORT.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
OKAY SAY NINE WILL BRING BACK
THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
YES -- OVER HERE AND YOU THEY
STARTED READY.
WHAT IS IT?
OKAY SURVIVE NGUYEN ANYONE ONLY
NOW. THIRTY ONE OF FORTY ONE YES
WHATEVER WE'RE ABOUT TO VOTE ON
THAT SO WHY DON'T WE JUST.
IF.
IF YOU IF YOU WANT TO BE BEFORE
WE DO THIS VOTE.
OR WOULD YOU RATHER WAIT FOR
THIS VOTE.
OKAY SO WAS THIS FINISHES ALLEN
AND STOP THIS FORM AND DO ALL
THE VOTE.
SO CENTER MORE LOCK BUT IF.
SOMEONE'S ABOUT THE LABEL STUFF.
FOR SENATE ROTH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I I I HAVE. TWO RESIDENCES
BOTH CURRENCY ID'S AND I'M
TRYING TO VISUALIZE THIS AND I
AM.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION HERE.
YOU'LL FIND THAT THE PEOPLE IN A
TWO WAYS ARE VERY CONFLICTED
BECAUSE OF MANY OF THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR H. O.
IN TRUCKEE THEY'VE BEEN
CLAMORING FOR YEARS TO THE
ABILITY TO BUILD IN A DEAL ON
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEY'VE BEEN
TOLD BY THE H..
AWAY NOW SO ACROSS THE STREET
THEY GOT PROPERTIES VACATION
HOMES ON THE VERY SIMILAR SIZE
LOT SIMILAR SIZE DESIGN
EVERYTHING ELSE AND THEY THEY
CAN BUILD EIGHT EIGHTY YOU AND
THEY CAN'T SO I THINK YOU'LL SEE
THAT THERE'S THE H. AWAY
ASSOCIATION THAT WE MET WITH WE
SPENT A LOT.
OF TIME WITH PEOPLE
REPRESENTATION WAYS -- AND WE'VE.
I TO CRAFT SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAN LIVE WITH THAT'S WHY THEY
ARE NOT HERE CLOSING THE BILL OF
THOSE I LET THEM SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES BUT WE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME WITH THE PEOPLE
REPRESENTING YOUR CHOICE.
AND THEY WERE PROPOSALS TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THEY SAID
NOT ON YOUR LIFE FROM THEIR OWN
MEMBERSHIP WE'RE SAYING WE WILL
EVEN YOU'RE NOT GOING TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL IT'S GOING TO GIVE.
BALANCE THE PROPERTY RIGHTS OF
BOTH THE EXISTING OWNERS AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
THIS OPTION THAT THEY LOOK
ACROSS THE STREET SAY WE LIKE
KEVIN AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT
OUR PROPERTY.
THANK YOU THINK ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY I'VE SEEN NONE -- WE WILL --
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL -- WE NEED EIGHTY
USE AND WE NEED TO BE SERIOUS
THAT WE THE STOP ALLOWING YOU TO
ALWAYS OR CITIES.
TO CONSTRUCTING -- VISIT ISSUES
OF THANK YOU.
OKAY FIRST RUN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
SENATOR WIENER PRESENT WIENER
PRESENT MORALE.
ROLL PRESENT BATES EVER DRAWS OF
RATHER PRESENT MCGUIRE MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT ROUGH.
ROUGH PRESENT SKINNER.
SKINNER PRESENT UMBERG CASKEY.
THIS IS THE THIRD.
SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
OKAY THIS BILL -- AB SIX SEVENTY
TO MOVE I CENTER SKINNER AND WE
WILL AND I'M SORRY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AND JUST AS FAR AS
I CAN REMEMBER I DON'T THINK
WE'VE HAD ANY NO VOTES ON THIS
SO JUST WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT.
BY RAWSON BUT BY PERSONAL THE
WAY WE'VE THE FIRST OPPOSITION
TO SHOW UP ON THURSDAY.
THAT'S A GREAT CHILDREN THAT'S
WHAT TIME TO BE CHANGED OKAY --
WE'LL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
SENATOR WIENER [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
SENATOR WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE FOR L.
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
TOMORROW.
BROTHER.
BROTHER I MCGUIRE MORE LUCK.
ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE THE CASKEY
[inaudible]
GOVERNOR [inaudible]
SENATE COVER [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
HOWEVER I THANK YOU ALL.
OKAY IT'S FIVE GO TO PUT THAT ON
CALL -- FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO GO BACK AND VOTE ON
CHECK OUT -- HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE A CA.
ONE OF WHICH WAS HEARD -- MOTION
BY.
SENATOR ROTH -- WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS ISN'T A CONSTITUTIONAL
MOMENT ONE BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND WE'RE
FOR THE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MOREAU.
MORRELL AYE BATES CAMARO.
EVER I DRAWS LOW.
AROUSAL I AM MCGUIRE MOORLACH.
ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE UMBERG CASKEY.
THE OTHER SIX VOTES AND WE'LL
PUT THAT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS -- WE WILL NOW ALL OUR
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM NUMBER.
TWO THE BY CENTER ROTH.
THIS IS ONLY THE ONE FORTY FOR
YOU BASED ON THE NUMBER QUIRK
SILVA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND WE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
AMARO.
MORRELL NO BATES COVER.
COVER I DRAWS ADRUG SO I AM
ACQUIRE MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE UMBERG BECAUSE HE
OKAY AT SIXTY ONE WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL NOW -- ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
I SENATOR SKINNER HAS -- MOTION
MOVED TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONCERT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEMS THREE FIVE AND SEVEN
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE BATES COVER.
COVER I DRAWS A BROTHER I AM
ACQUIRE.
MORE LOOK MORE LIKE HI ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE.
CASKEY.
OKAY SEVEN ZERO PUT THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY WE'VE NOW ALL ARE GOING
THROUGH THE WHOLE GENDER
SEPARATE AND SIX AND IF YOU KNOW
SOMEONE NUMBER GONZALEZ ARRIVES
WILL TAKE THAT OFF SHE ON OUR
WAY [inaudible]
WHY?
THE ATTACKS ARE [inaudible]
THANK
.
HEY WELCOMEASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ WILL CALL ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY WELCOME
[inaudible]
SURE MEMBERS.
BACK IN A HOUSING COMMITTEE
ABOUT A TRANSPORTATION BILL.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THE HELL MY
REFERRALS HAVE GONE THIS YEAR
BUT THE SECOND TIME.
SO AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY WOULD
EXTEND THE DEADLINE -- FOR SAN
DIEGO ASSOCIATION GOVERNMENTS TO
FINALIZE A NEW REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN BY TWO YEARS
HISTORICALLY SANDBAG HAS BEEN
CRITICIZED APPROPRIATELY FOR NOT
PRIORITIZING INVESTING ENOUGH
PUBLIC TRANSIT BIKE AND
PEDESTRIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS THE
AGENCY HAS GONE THROUGH DRAMATIC
CHANGE LARGELY THROUGH
LEGISLATION WE ARE AND ABLE --
TO AND CHANGE THE DIRECTION AND
LEADERSHIP OF SANDBAGS.
WHEN US AND DAD BEGAN TO WORK ON
UPDATE RTP FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT THE CURRENT
CONCEPTS WOULDN'T MEET THE 19%
TARGET -- THAT'S A TARGET THAT
THEY HAD THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCE BOARD FINALIZE NEW
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION TARGETS
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES I'M FROM
13219%.
AND EVEN A MEANINGFUL CHANGE HAS
OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF RECENT
SCANDAL AND RESTRUCTURING OF THE
BOARD WE KNOW THAT WE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO MEET WHAT IT WOULD BE
A FALSE -- PLAN AND SO WE'RE
ASKING FOR TWO YEAR EXTENSION IN
ORDER TO PUT FORWARD A PLAN THAT
WILL ACTUALLY MEET THOSE GOALS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
HI I GET AFTERNOON ROBIN WAGNER
WITH THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENTS THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE WE'RE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER AND PROUD
SPONSORSHIP OF ASSEMBLY BILL --
SEVENTEEN THIRTY EARLIER THIS
YEAR THE SANTA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS WHICH IS COMPRISED OF
EACH OF THE LOCAL CITIES AND THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED AN ACTION PLAN. TO TAKE
THE TIME THAT WE NEED TO CREATE
A TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF ALL SAN
DIEGANS A TRANSPORTATION PLAN
THAT NOT ONLY MEETS BUT EXCEEDS
OUR STATE CLIMATE GOALS.
AND REALLY CREATES TRUE MOBILITY
TRACES THAT HELPS ALL PEOPLE GET
WHERE THEY WANT TO GO WHEN THEY
WANT TO GO AND HOW THEY WANT TO
GO.
IN ORDER TO DO THIS SO IN TO DO
IT RIGHT WE NEED MORE TIME AND
SO SOME LEGAL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
GIVES US AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS
TO CREATE A TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
THAT TRULY WILL TRANSFORM THE
WAY THAT PEOPLE AND GOODS MOVED
THROUGHOUT THE REGION IT ALSO
PRESERVES OUR CURRENT LENA AND
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATE TIME
LINES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
TAKE THE ACTIONS THAT WE NEED.
TO ADDRESS THOSE URGENT NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NOT THIS COMMITTEE IS SO --
URGENTLY FOCUSED ON SO LIKE I
SAID WE HAVE CORNY TO WITH ALL
OF OUR JURISDICTIONS WE ENJOY A
STRONG SUPPORT FROM ACROSS THE
REGION VERY STAKEHOLDERS -- AND
WE'RE VERY VERY THANKFUL THAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS AGREED
TO RUN THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF US
THAT WE CAN TAKE THE TIME TO DO
THIS RIGHT.
WE RESPECT YOUR QUESTION I FELT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO -- MAYOR KEVIN
FAULCONER AND THE CITY COUNCIL
HAVE EMBARKED UPON A AN
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
AS WELL AS HOUSING INITIATIVES
IN RECENT YEARS -- AND WE SEE
STAND I GUESS OUR PARTNERS IN
ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS
AND WE HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF EFFORTS AND AND IT TOO TO
REFORM STAND ACT -- TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PARTNERSHIP IS STRONG
SO THAT WE CAN MEET THESE
AGGRESSIVE GOALS THAT WE'VE
PLACED.
UPON OURSELVES -- WE THINK
HURRIEDLY PUTTING TOGETHER A A
PLAN OF THE SCS IN RTP SIMPLY TO
MEET -- THE DEADLINE WON'T SERVE
ANYBODY'S PURPOSES WHILE TAKING
AN EXTRA TWO YEARS TO GET THE
PLAN DONE PROPERLY -- IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO -- AND WE WE
DO SUPPORT THE MEASURE WERE A
SPONSOR A CO SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE WITH OUR PARTNERS AND
SANDBAG ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
IN BILL HIGGINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS AND I'M
HERE TO PERHAPS OFFER A
STATEWIDE -- PERSPECTIVE MY
BOARD JUST TOOK A SUPPORT
POSITION ON THIS BILL ON
WEDNESDAY WHICH IS WHY YOU DON'T
HAVE A LETTER IN FRONT OF YOU.
RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD SAY JUST
GENERALLY ABOUT THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IN THE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT COMMUNITY
VISIONING DOCUMENT.
N. IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
VISION THE OPT OUT BY END.
AND WHAT I'M HEARING FROM THE
SPONSORS AND THE REASON FOR THIS
IS THIS IS TO GIVE THE COMMUNITY
A CHANCE TO BUILD A NEW VISION
FOR THE REGION.
AND THAT TAKES TIME BECAUSE IN
ORDER TO DO IT FROM A TECHNICAL
STANDPOINT.
HAVE TO DEVELOP A VISION
INTEGRATE YOUR SEQUEL -- RUN
YOUR TRAVEL MODELS DO YOUR SEE
I'M SORRY TO INTEGRATE YOUR
ARENA AND THEN DO YOUR
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND THAT
ALL TAKES TIME IN FACT -- A
TYPICAL REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLAN FROM START TO FINISH TAKES
ALMOST FOUR YEARS WE WE WE ADOPT
ONE AND THEN.
THE PLANNERS GOING CELEBRATE FOR
A WEEKEND AND THEN THEY COME
BACK ON MONDAY WORK ON THE NEXT.
ONE AND SO THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO DO THIS IN A SHORTER
AMOUNT OF TIME AND GET IT DONE
IT TO THE FINISH SIGNED AND AND
TO HAVE A VISION THAT THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS.
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVES CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS.
GREAT IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
JOHNSON CLAIMED AFTER THE CITY
EVEN SENATORS THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
CATHERINE OCCURRED ON ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD IN
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY THING NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
FEMALE WILL BRING ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
YES I SENATOR CABALLERO AND THEN
CENTER LIKE HUSKY.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING --
THANK YOU TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HER WORK AT MAKING SOME
CHANGES AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL I
THINK IT'S SOME IT'S BEEN
IMPORTANT AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT -- THOSE CHANGES
ARE GONNA.
BE OOD FOR THE COMMUNITY I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION THIS IS FAIRLY
UNUSUAL IN TERMS OF A WAY TO DO
BUSINESS -- IS THERE ANY OTHER
COUNTY THAT HAS -- THIS KIND OF
ISSUE.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF I WOULD
SAY THAT -- SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE EIGHTEEN METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATION THERE'S NO
EASY PATHWAY TO THE NEXT ROUND
OF TARGETS.
SENDEK SITUATION IS UNIQUE BUT I
KNOW THAT FOR EXAMPLE AMONG THE
OTHER LARGE NPOS THE SACRAMENTO
AREA COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS.
IS ALSO STRUGGLING TO MEET THEIR
TARGET A 19% AND ARE SEEKING
SOME NEW BUDGET INVESTMENTS THAT
THEY THAT THEY'RE ASKING YOU.
FOR SO THE THIRD DIFFERENT
PATHWAYS TO GET TO WHAT THAT FIX
THE IS.
BUT THE ROAD THE THE ROAD TO
ACHIEVING MORE MORE REDUCTIONS
WITH EACH PERCENTAGE INCREASE IT
GETS TOUGHER AND TOUGHER BECAUSE
THE LOW HANGING FRUIT IS GONE.
SO -- I THINK I THINK THAT THIS
IS A VERY GOOD PILOT IS HOW I
KIND OF THINK ABOUT IT TO SEE
YOU B	C IF YOU CAN ACTUALLY GO
BACK AND RETOOL.
I SUSPECT THAT SOME OF THE
VISION IN THAT THEY COME BACK
WITH -- GOING TO PUSH US ALL IN
A POLICY STANDPOINT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN OUR OUR WE'RE ALL
GOING TO GET THERE TO MEET THE
GOAL.
SO THAT'S AND IF I CAN --
SENATOR YOU MAY REMEMBER WHEN I
DID THE BILL BEFORE IN FACT A
LOT OF YOU I HAD EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- PROBABLY
AT THE TIME I THINK ON LOCAL GOV --
IT WAS UNUSUAL WHAT WE DID THEN
AND WE UP ENDED THE ENTIRE
AGENCY IN YOU IT IS -- ALMOST
LIKE NIGHT AND DAY AND SO WHAT I
THINK WE WOULD HAVE HAD BEFORE
THIS KIND OF TOTAL
REORGANIZATION AND AN SOMETHING
THAT IN IT OUT REALLY GOOD FOR
ENTIRE REGION -- I WOULD ARGUE.
DEFINITELY THE PART THAT I LIVE
IN -- ENDED UP HAVING NEW
LEADERSHIP HAVING NEW VISION
INCLUDING THE VOICES OF PEOPLE
WHO HADN'T BEEN IN SOME OF THE
REGIONAL PLANNING WE WE COULD
THEY COULD DO A PLAN IT WON'T
MEET ITS GOALS.
IT THEY'LL KNOW THAT IT'S IT'S
NOT A GOOD PLAN THEY'LL GET SUED --
AND WILL BE IN COURT AND THEY'LL
HAVE TO GO MAKE A NEW PLAN I I
THINK IT'S A GESTURE OF GOOD
WILL THAT THE LEADERSHIP IN EVEN.
ALL SIDES OF KIND OF THE DEBATE
ON WHERE WE'RE GOING WITH WITH
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND WITH
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSIT AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GASES WERE
NOT.
MONOLITHIC IN OUR COUNTY ABOUT
WHERE WE SHOULD GO BUT DESPITE
THAT EVERYBODY WHETHER IT'S THE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY PEOPLE WHO WANT MORE
ROADS PEOPLE WHO WANT MORE
TRANSIT ARE ALL ON BOARD WITH
THIS -- APPROACH BECAUSE WE'VE
NEVER HAD COMMUNITY INPUT LIKE
THAT SO WE'VE NEVER HAD THE
ABILITY SO I UNDERSTAND IT'S
UNUSUAL -- AND AND I KNOWS
DIFFERENT COUNTIES PROBABLY ARE
DEALING WITH DIFFERENT THINGS
BUT WE WE TRULY BECAUSE OF OF
SCANDALS IN BECAUSE OF A A
VOTING STRUCTURE THAT REALLY
LEFT COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE OUT
OF THE OUT OF THE COMMUNITY.
THE PROCESS OF ENGAGEMENT FOR
DECADES -- WERE IN A UNIQUE
POSITION AND I KNOW.
IT'S KIND OF FUNNY TO LOOK AT
THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE I KNOW --
CENTER WOULD HOUSE HE HAD
PROBLEMS WITH MY BILL AND EIGHT
I CAN'T ON THIS ONLY WAY WE CAN
DO IT I KNOW I WORKED REALLY
HARD WITH -- CENTER MCGUIRE -- I
KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT WE WERE DOING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM HERE AND SO WE
WE I HAD SO MANY OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS BUT NOW WE'RE IN A
POSITION WHERE IN A MUCH BETTER-SPOT I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD IT.
NOT EVERYBODY MOST PEOPLE WOULD
AGREE THAT.
DEATH THE MAJORITY OF THE COUNTY
WOULD AGREE TO THAT -- AND WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO GET THIS --
TRANSPORTATION PLAN RIGHT SO
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES SO SO I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THE REASON
FOR THE QUESTION IS THAT -- MANY
TIMES WE DO ONE OFF BILLS.
AND AND THERE AND THEN THERE'S A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE
AFTERWARDS THAT ARE SAYING WORK
WE'RE HAVING THE SAME ISSUES AND
SO I WANT TO BE FAIR.
IN THIS PROCESS -- BUT I ALSO
WANT TO BE VERY TRANSPARENT
ABOUT ABOUT WHAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE AND MAYBE WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS GO BACK AND RETOOL.
THE DATES.
AND HOW WE SET UP THE
OBLIGATIONS BECAUSE THERE THE
BOTTOM LINE IS WE'VE SET THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
AND WE SAID EVERYBODY HAS TO
ACHIEVE THEM.
AND THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES YOU
WON'T GET TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS
IF YOU'RE NOT ARE YOU.
OR YOUR AIR BOARD IS NOT GOING
TO GET THAT THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES.
AND AND MY CONCERN AND I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA SUPPORT IF YOU'VE DONE.
GOOD WORK ON IT BUT BUT IN
REALITY WHAT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE TAKING AN OLD SECRET
DOCUMENT THAT IS NOT GOING TO BE
APPLICABLE. TO THE NEW WHATEVER
IS GOING TO BE AND AND SO IT'S
SIXTY CA EXEMPTION RIGHT --
AND I AND I IT AND IT WE JUST
NEED TO ASK WE NEED TO CALL THIS
OUT AND SAY MAYBE WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IS IF WE HAVE OTHER
COUNTIES THAT MIGHT BE.
IN THE IN A VERY SIMILAR
POSITION -- MAYBE AT JUST THE
DATES. FOR WHICH ON REPORTER DO.
AND THE CYCLES -- IS SO THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST DOING A ONE OFF
FOR SOMEBODY BUT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO GIVE THE FLEXIBILITY.
AND WILL SAY DURING THIS DURING
THIS NEXT CYCLE WE'RE NOT GOING
TO MESS AROUND WITH ALL THE ANY
OF THE TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS.
IN OTHER WORDS YOU'RE NOT GOING.
TO WE'RE NOT GOING TO SAY YOU'RE
NOT ELIGIBLE WE'RE GONNA LET BUT
EVERYBODY'S IN THE SAME POSITION
BECAUSE WE'VE ADJUSTED THE CYCLE
THAT'S THAT JUST MY CONCERN
BECAUSE WHEN I WENT.
AS I WENT THROUGH IT IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S A LITTLE BIT IT.
BACKWARDS -- WERE USING A SECRET
DOCUMENT TO SATISFY THE FEDS AND
THEN AND THEN WE'RE YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE DOING THAT --
THE REAL PLANNING THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IT'S KIND OF LIKE -- JUST
TAKE CARE OF THEM THIS ISN'T
REALLY REAL BUT BUT IN REALITY --
THAT HAS CONSEQUENCES AND SO
ANYWAY I THAT JUST MIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMENTS AND
I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IT
AFFECTING MORE THAN JUST ONE
COUNTY.
BUT I I DO APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HAD I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO FIND MORE
COUNTIES ARE IN THE SAME
POSITION [inaudible]
ENTER ACOSTA.
WITH A BICYCLE.
QUESTIONS FOR EQ MY AS A
PLANNING PROCESS.
AND I GUESS I'M ASKING FOR BEST
PRACTICES DO WE THINK THAT BY
THIS EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME TO
DO THE MULTI MODAL PLANNING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES IN
THAT.
THE SAN DIEGO AREA IS GONNA BE
ON TARGET TO DO TAKE TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TARGETS BUT
ALSO WE HAVE TARGETS FOR TWENTY
FORTY SO SO THAT'S MY QUESTION
IS THIS IS A PLANNING INSTRUMENT
OKAY WE REALIZE WERE OFF COURSE.
CAN WE ADJUSTED NOW AND THEN
GIVEN THE POWERS THAT BE IN THE
NEXT.
FEDERATION IS GOING TO BE ON
TARGET I THINK -- WHAT YOU'LL
FIND IS OUR OUR PLANS ARE NOW
TAKE SEE THOSE TARGETS -- AND SO.
WE'VE REALLY.
I CAN'T POSSIBLY DESCRIBE TO YOU
HOW DIFFERENT OF AN AGENCY WE
HAVE TODAY THAN WE EVEN HAD.
YOU KNOW A YEAR AGO OR TWO YEARS
AGO AND SO -- IT IS AT OUR IT IS
THE STATED PURPOSE OF THE SEA
AND DAD BOARD TO EXCEED THOSE
TARGETS WITH COMMUNITY INPUT
THAT MAKES SENSE SO YEAH I THINK
YOU'LL FIND THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- THAT'S A MOVE THE BILL A
MOVE BY CENTER CABALLERO AND US
SOME ROAD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND SENATE MCGUIRE THE DO YOU
ORDER CENTER UMBER GET THEM
ACQUIRE AWARD FOR TODAY NO I
BELIEVE IT'S AYE NAMED AFTER CAR
LARA AND I THINK YOU SHOULD GO
TO CENTER NUMBER TODAY -- SO
CONGRATULATIONS CENTER I'M VERY.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT'S FOR
IT'S FOR THE IT'S FOR THE MEMBER
WHO ARRIVED LAST.
AND IT STARTED IN THIS IN YOUR
EYES.
BY STRADIVARI GOT.
ITS START IN GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND WAS CALLED THE
RICARDO LARA WORD AND SO NOW WE
HAVE THE MIKE MCGUIRE ORIGINS.
WELCOME TO THE SENATE SENATE
SOMEONE OVER.
I WAS HERE.
I JUST.
NO SUCH REWARD.
OKAY WELL -- WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION -- AND WE WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
THIRTY BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER
THE COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL.
HI MORRELL AYE BATES CARRERO.
EVER I DRAWS A BROWSER I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MOORLACH.
ROUGH [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
I'M BURKE AYE CASKEY FIVE CASKEY.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT WILL PUT IT
ON CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARE THOUGHT OUT YET HAS NOT
THOSE TO BE OUT -- OKAY -- WE
NOW CONTROL THAT I AM THE AGENDA
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR MEMBERS
WHO WERE NOT HERE AND WILL YOU
THAT AND KEEP.
THEM GENERALLY OPEN BECAUSE
THERE ARE STILL MEMBERS NOT HERE --
SO WE WILL START WITH A ITEM
NUMBER ONE AND WILL.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ONE IS A CA.
ONE THIS ISN'T A CONSTITUTIONAL
MOMENT ONE BY SENATOR ALLEN THE
MOTION IS THE ADOPTED AND WE
WERE FOR THE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
BATES.
MCGUIRE.
YES.
NINE ZERO OKAY DIED -- SCA ONE
ITEM ONE IS NINE THE BILL IS
NINE ZERO AND NOT BILL OR THAT --
SCA IS OUT -- OKAY NEXT WOULD
ITEM TO AB.
ONE FORTY THREE WE'LL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS ONLY THE
ONE FORTY FOR YOU BASED ON THE
NUMBER QUIRK SILVA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATOR BATES.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
OKAY CI. SEVENTY TO ONE OKAY.
THE VOTE IS -- NINE TO ONE SO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY NEXT I NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN -- WE
WILL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS A MAY BILL NUMBER SIX
SEVENTY BY SOME A MEMBER
FRIEDMAN MOTIONS YOU PASS AND
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
[inaudible]
SENATOR MORALE.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK.
UMBERG.
NUMBER I CASKEY FIVE BECAUSE HE
I AND THE SMELL COMING BACK.
IS NOT GONNA.
I SET UP NORTH WITH AN EX OKAY
VOTERS -- EIGHT ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT -- WILL OF THE CALL ON
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ.
THIS IS ONLY A BILL SEVENTEEN
THIRTY BASED ON THE NUMBER
GONZALEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SENATOR BATES.
BARLACH.
ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER [inaudible]
ISSUE COMING.
WHERE -- SENT YES YOU DID WELL --
SO ENOUGH AS IT IS NOW ABOUT.
I HOPE SO.
AS ROCK PROBLEMS WITH.
OKAY IT TO A MECHANIC OKAY SO
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE ITEM SIX ON
CALL.
I NEXT WE WILL MOVE TO THE
CONSENT AGENDA.
NIXON CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF
FILE ITEMS THREE FIVE AND SEVEN
SENATOR BATES.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM BERG.
I'M VERY FIVE CASKEY.
CASKEY I RIVER BASIN.
OKAY SAYS TEN ZERO ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA -- AND IT IS
THEREFORE ADOPTED.
OKAY SO AT THIS POINT WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ON CALL IT OF NUMBER
SIX A. B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY WE
ARE GOING -- TO WAIT FOR THE OUT
TO MEMBERS OKAY IT'S A SENATE
[inaudible]
THE ON NINE ONE SIX SIX EIGHT
ZERO RIGHT NOW OKAY WHICH IS
WHAT
.
AND SEX AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS UNABLE SEVENTEEN THIRTY OF
US IN THE MEMBER GONZALEZ THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY SENATOR BATES.
MORLOCK SKINNER. FIVE SKINNER
AYE.
OKAY -- NINE ZERO IS A VOTE ON
THAT BILL IS OUT AND YES OKAY
THAT COMPUTER BUSINESS TODAY
THANK YOU WE ARE ADJOURNED